monsieur le ministre cher bruno mes
chers collègues votre audition monsieur
le ministre vient clore deux journées
particulièrement remplie pour notre
commission qui nous ont permis
d'entendre d'autres ministres agnès
pannier rue lâcher et olivier klein sur
leur feuille de route pour les prochains
mois comme cela était initialement prévu
mais aussi sur la crise énergétique
actuelle crise qui impacte tous les
secteurs d'activité j'ai d'ailleurs
souhaité que la commission se penche sur
ces questions avant même le début de la
session ordinaire et le cycle
d'auditions des ministres a été complété
par un cycle d'auditions spécifiquement
sur l'énergie qui nous a déjà permis
d'entendre outre agnès pannier rue lâché
le pdg d'edf ce matin et le président de
rte juste avant tout à l'heure la
présente édition doit dès lors vous
permettre de nous exposer les grandes
lignes de la politique économique que
vous souhaitez mener dans les prochains
mois et nous faire part des textes de
lois que nous pourrions être conduit à
examiner pour mettre en oeuvre cette
politique mais il est évident que les
questions énergétiques pèseront sur vos
choix et constitueront un volet
essentiel de cette politique si nous
avons longuement évoquée au cours des
auditions précédentes les questions
liées à la fourniture et à la production
d'énergie d'une part et à la
consommation d'autre part les questions
des prix de l'énergie et de leur impact
sur l'économie n'a pas constitué le
sujet principal de nos interrogations ce
sont là des sujets que nous
approfondirons la semaine prochaine
mercredi 21 septembre lors d'une table
ronde réunissant plusieurs économistes
mais il nous faut aussi aborder
aujourd'hui ce sujet avec vous
le bouclier énergétique a permis aux
français de bénéficier d'une protection
contre la hausse des prix sans
équivalent en europe en plafonnant à 4 %
l'augmentation des tarifs de
l'électricité est en jeu l'an le prix du
gaz le gouvernement a annoncé il ya
quelques jours qu'un dispositif serait
maintenu en 2023 je crois que il ya eu
deux expressions aujourd'hui pouvez vous
nous en dire plus sur les modalités de
ce futur dispositif pour les entreprises
ou les collectivités locales les hausses
de tarifs sont immédiatement perceptible
ans et que vous avez déjà annoncé un
élargissement des mécanismes dead en
faveur de celles pour lesquelles les
achats de gaz ou d'électricité constitué
au moins 3 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
et cela n'empêche pas certains secteurs
d'être très inquiet est ce que d'autres
mesures sont en cours de préparation un
conseil extraordinaire des ministres
européens de l'énergie a eu lieu
vendredi dernier où en est on des
négociations sur le plafonnement du prix
du gaz russe et sur la contribution des
producteurs d'électricité profitant de
la flambée des prix les aides
ponctuelles fournis ne devront pas
effacé néanmoins le signal prix ce
signal prix qui doit permettre
d'orienter les investissements en
particulier ceux rendus nécessaires par
la transition énergétique et les
changements climatiques des réformes
structurelles devront aussi être engagée
en particulier s'agissant de la
formation des prix de l'électricité sur
le marché européen question sur laquelle
vous vous êtes souvent exprimée ce
dossier petit l'avancé rapidement avec
nos partenaires européens voilà toutes
les questions qui vont bientôt arriver
monsieur le ministre je vous propose de
prendre la parole pour un propos
introductifs de votre choix et ensuite
je donnerai la parole aux différents
groupes qui s'exprimeront et ensuite je
prendrai toutes les questions
individuelles m monsieur le ministre la
parole est à vous
merci monsieur le président cher
guillaume mesdames et messieurs les
députés
très heureux d'avoir l'occasion de
préciser la stratégie qui est la nôtre
depuis maintenant plus de 14 mois pour
faire face à la flambée des prix du gaz
et de l'électricité
premiers éléments nous avons fait un
choix stratégique avec le président de
la république en octobre 2021 qui est
d'anticiper l'augmentation des prix
l'électricité les prix du gaz en mettant
en place un bouclier énergétique je
reconnais bien volontiers que lorsque
nous l'avons mise en place nous
n'anticipons pas une telle flambée mais
nous anticipions une augmentation des
prix eh bien nous en a pris parce que
c'est ce qui a permis de maîtriser
l'inflation en france est de maîtriser
le choc pour nos compatriotes comme pour
les entreprises
nous avons gelé les prix du gaz à
compter d'octobre 2000 interne et nous
avons plafonner les prix de
l'électricité à hauteur de 4% ce qui
veut dire que depuis octobre 2021 les
prix n'augmentent pas sur leur facture
pour nos compatriotes
je le dis à sa tombe de députés qui
disent la grande bretagne c'est beaucoup
mieux qu'ils aillent en grande bretagne
où la facture a augmenté jusqu'à 600
livres en moyenne par mois je pense pas
que ce soit le modèle chez nous là pas
bougé donc je préfère le modèle français
au modèle britannique et je préfère la
protection que nous avons apportées
à celle qui a été apportée par d'autres
pays européens nous avons décidé de
prolonger ce bouclier énergétique au
regard de la situation des prix du gaz
du prix d'électricité la première
ministre vient de l'annoncer nous
maintiendrons un bouclier énergétique
pour l'ensemble des ménages à partir du
1er janvier 2023 mais comme les prix
augmentent 110 120 130 % avec une forte
variation d'un jour à l'autre d'une
semaine à l'autre nous avons également
décidé d'avoir une augmentation au 1er
janvier de 15 % des prix d'électricité
et de 15% des prix du gaz a comparé je
le redis aux 110 ou 120 % d'augmentation
qu'aurait subi nos compatriotes très
concrètement ça veut dire que en moyenne
sur une facture de gaz l'augmentation
sera de 25 euros elle aurait dû être de
200 euros donc vous voyez que nous avons
économisé 175 euros par ménage par foyer
sur le prix du gaz avec ce bouclier même
avec une augmentation contenu de 15 pour
soi même chose pour l'électricité avec
une augmentation qui sera contenue à 15%
nous avons également pris la décision
d'augmenter le chèque énergie de
l'étendre à 2 des cibles supplémentaires
et touchait deux premiers déciles nous
allons rajouter deux des cils pour que
soient les quatre premiers déciles qui
soit concerné ce chèque sera versé dans
les semaines qui viennent cela
représente un coût supplémentaire pour
les finances publiques de 1 8 milliard
d'euros c'est la même logique que nous
appliquons protéger l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes que personne n'ait à subir
des augmentations de sa facture qui
soient insupportables mais protéger
encore plus et de manière ciblée ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin c'est à dire
des ménages avec les revenus les plus
modestes
combien est-ce que coûte ce dispositif
un pour le bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz
cela coûte 11 milliards d'euros et comme
il n'y a pas de dispositif de
récupération de quelques recettes que ce
soit ces 11 me d'euros net
pour l'électricité cela nous coûte 5
milliards d'euros nets soit au total un
coût anticipé pour 2023 de 16 milliards
d'euros net pour ce bouclier tarifaires
mais je tiens à préciser parce que je
crois que là aussi c'est très important
de défendre le modèle français que le
coût brut sur l'électricité n'est pas de
5 mhz et 2 34 milliards d'euros que ce
que ça va nous coûter de financer la
différence entre les 15% d'augmentation
et 110 ou 120 qu'on peut anticiper pour
la suite c'est 34 milliards d'euros mais
nous récupérons sur ses 34 milliards
d'euros 9 milliards d'euros de tcf qui
sont supprimées et 19 milliards d'euros
de bénéfices qui sont faits par les
énergéticiens sur
l'électricité éolienne sur l'électricité
solaire et qu'il nous reverse c'est le
mécanisme qui était proposée par ursula
von der leyen et qui est l'extension au
niveau européen du mécanisme français je
veux bien faire comprendre ce mécanisme
qui est absolument essentiel pour les
finances publiques et que par ailleurs
il a inspiré le mécanisme européen nous
garantissons à tous les énergéticiens
depuis des années un prix sur le rachat
du kilowattheure solaire ou éolien ce
qui est une incitation pour ces
énergéticiens investir nous on
investissait dans l'éolien récit dans le
solaire nous coûtera rien de toute façon
si les prix sont trop bas on vous
compense le manque à gagner donc il me
paraît parfaitement légitime que lorsque
les prix sont au dessus de ce prix
garanti
c'est l'état qui récupère la mise et
c'est ce mécanisme de marché qui était
proposée par la commission européenne
est un mécanisme justes efficaces qui
évite que les énergéticiens puisse
disposer de rente énergétique à
l'occasion de la flambée de ses prix de
l'énergie
s'agissant des entreprises nous avons
trois mécanismes pour les protéger vous
avez d'abord les plus petites
entreprises celles qu un chiffre
d'affaires inférieur à 2 millions
d'euros et moins de 10 salariés elle
elles ont accès aux tarifs réglementés
dont elles sont déjà protégés après vous
avez les pme qui font un chiffre
d'affaires plus importants qui peuvent
avoir accès à une aide de 2 millions
d'euros la seule condition pour avoir
accès à cette aide c'est que la facture
d'énergie représentent au moins 3 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires il faut
également que la facture est doublé
entre l'année passée et cette année mais
c'est le cas de toutes les entreprises
au regard des montants de tarifs de
l'électricité et du gaz
nous avions des dispositifs et des
critères qui étaient beaucoup trop
contraignants sur se dit sheila nous les
avons simplifié les nouveaux critères
entreront en vigueur au 1er octobre ce
qui veut dire que partir du 1er octobre
il suffira de remplir ces deux
conditions et d'accuser une baisse de
ses bénéfices sur le mois passé pour
pouvoir avoir accès à ces deux millions
d'euros dead j'ai bon espoir que cela
débloquera le mécanisme et permettra au
maximum de pme d'aller au guichet la
dgesip et recevoir jusqu'à 2 millions
d'euros dead ensuite il ya ce qu'on
appelle des nerfs ou intensif c'est à
dire les entreprises qui dépense
particulièrement
d'argent pour financer leur électricité
où l'orgasme ça peut être des aciéries
ça peut être de la chimie c'est peut
être des verriers ça peut être des gens
qui font du carton du papier ça fait
beaucoup d'entreprises là je le dis très
simplement le dispositif à 25 et 45
millions d'euros dont nous avions déjà
dire la commission européenne depuis le
départ qui était infiniment trop
complexe ne marche pas il ya donc
urgence à le réformer j'ai demandé à la
commission européenne à ce qu'il soit
réformée avant la fin de l'année 2022 et
c'est pas faute d'avoir dit et expliqué
depuis le début à longueur de réunion
que ce dispositif était trop complexe il
ya urgence à le simplifier
enfin je précise que nous allons
évidemment prolonger ces dispositifs
au delà du 31 décembre de cette année
n'est pas question d'arrêter de soutien
aux entreprises au moins elle pourrait
en avoir le plus besoin nous
maintiendrons donc ces dispositifs au
delà du 31 décembre 2000 22 pour que les
entreprises soient bien protégés
un mot enfin sur les mécanismes
européens
nous nous travaillons sur des achats
communs d'énergie je pense que c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus efficace nous
travaillons sur un plafonnement des prix
du gaz nous travaillons également et je
pense que nous sommes en bonne voie pour
répondre à votre question sur la
déconnexion définitive des prix du gaz
et des prix de l'électricité j'avais
écrit au président de l'eurogroupe en
octobre 2021 donc il y à peu près un an
pour réclamer cette déconnexion je pense
que nous sommes en bonne voie de
l'obtenir il ya une véritable aberration
avoir des prix d'électricité décarbonée
qui sont indexées sur le coût marginal
d'ouverture la dernière centrale à gaz
tout ça n'a absolument aucun sens et
donc nous sommes en voie d'obtenir gain
de cause sur ce sujet là donc les
urgences aujourd'hui elles sont très
simples mettre en place des mécanismes
plus simple pour soutenir les
entreprises
déconnecté du prix du gaz de prix
l'électricité avoir des achats communs
de façon à pouvoir plafonner les prix ce
qui est pas de plafonnement de prise
sans achats communs tout cela est en
bonne voie et je pense que les idées que
nous défendons depuis maintenant plus
d'un an le président la république sont
en passe d'être adopté par l'union
européenne un dernier mot enfin sur les
carburants comme vous le savez nous
avons mis en place ou longuement débattu
ensemble cet été une remise sur les
carburants de 30 centimes d'euros pour
un coût total de 7,6 milliards d'euros
cette remise permet à nos compatriotes
d'avoir accès à un carburant moins cher
au moment ils ont que j'ai besoin c'est
à dire au moment de la rentrée ces
remises à la pompe vont s'éteindre
progressivement d'ici décembre 2022 nous
verrons ensuite où nous en sommes au
début 2023 est ce que le prix du baril
reste à 85,90 dollars c'est-à-dire un
prix qui est mesuré ce que nous espérons
est ce que des événements extérieurs
font flamber le prix du baril à nous
adapterons les dispositifs à ce moment
là en tout état de cause nous passerons
quoi qu'il arrive à des dispositifs
ciblés notamment sur ceux qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix que les utilisent leur
voiture pour travailler mais il est trop
tôt pour dire des dispositifs qui
pourraient être retenues
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
je vais donc passer aux orateurs de
groupe je vous rappelle le
fonctionnement de cette audition chaque
orateur deux groupes disposent de quatre
minutes pour interroger monsieur le
ministre
quatre minutes inclut la réponse de
monsieur le ministre et donc je vous
engage à faire des questions courtes
vous pouvez comme l'a fait monsieur
jumelles d'ailleurs ce matin poser des
questions en 10 secondes 15 secondes 20
secondes ça marche très bien ça laisse
du temps de réponse vous pouvez vraiment
reposé une ensuite du moment vous restez
dans les quatre minutes près certains
préfèrent utiliser un beaucoup de temps
pour poser leur question monsieur le
ministre et vont jusqu'à deux minutes 2
minutes 30 maximum 3 à 3 coupes pour
vous laisser toujours une minute de
réponse quoi qu'il arrive surveillons
bien le chrono est en tout cas je vous
fais signe quand on arrive aux quatre
minutes on commence donc par monsieur
paul midy pour le groupe renaissance
c'est à vous
merci monsieur le président merci à
monsieur le ministre alors dans cette
crise d'énergie et puis débute cette
mandature on a eu pas mal de débats sur
des taxes supplémentaires pour les aînés
énergéticiens notamment et ça a été
notamment la taxe dite sur les
surprofits et ça a été l'occasion pour
la majorité présentielle de réaffirmer
sa volonté de baisser les impôts plutôt
que de les augmenter pourquoi
principalement parce que notre objectif
d'obtenir le plein emploi à la fin de ce
quinquennat qu'on veut donc créer
un environnement économique favorable à
la création d'emplois
que nous sommes le seul point de départ
le pays champion du monde des
prélèvements obligatoires et que donc
pour ça il faut baisser ses impôts c'est
ce que nous avons fait pendant cinq ans
notamment sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
qui est passée de 33% à 25 % et avec des
bons résultats sur l'emploi puisque nous
avons fait la moitié du chemin
entre là où nous étions il ya cinq ans
et cet objectif du plein emploi donc
évidemment on veut continuer
pour autant
si on veut que les impôts baissent on
veut que tout le monde l'ait paix et qui
est une vraie équité face à l'impôt et
là il ya un sujet qui a été soulevé par
certains sur la taxation des
multinationales et en particulier les
géants du numérique
qui ont par la nature de l'activité une
capacité beaucoup plus facile de
mettre leurs revenus dans les pays non
pas en france mais dans les pays dans la
fiscalité est beaucoup plus favorable
qu'en france et donc d'une certaine
façon d'échapper à l'impôt même si elles
ne font pas forcément des choses qui
sont
illégales alors il ya une solution
à cette difficulté qui qui d'ailleurs
est une dispute idées de fond
le jour où l'inflation redescendra et le
jour où la crise de l'énergie sera fini
on aura toujours ce problème il ya une
solution qui est l'impôt universelle
mondiale et c'est la réforme proposée
par le c2 que vous avez porté très
fortement avec le président de la
république avec un premier pilier qui
est
de faire en sorte que les
multinationales soient taxées dans le
pays où elle crée de la richesse et de
l'activité et un 2e pilier un impôt
minimal pour limiter les paradis fiscaux
alors vous avez pris des initiatives
récentes à ce sujet est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire qu'est ce que vous avez
en tête comme prochaine étape et quand
est ce que vous pensez que cette réforme
pourrait être mise en place d'une façon
effective messieurs ministre
d'abord sur le premier sujet qu'est la
position que nous défendons avec la
premier ministre et le président de la
république
nous ne voulons pas de rente
pas de rente énergétique et nous ne
voulons pas de taxation sur tout des
entreprises françaises parce que cela
abîmerait l'attractivité de notre
territoire
en revanche nous sommes favorables un
mécanisme de récupération de la rente
énergétique
est ce que propose de la présidente de
la commission européenne nous convient
parfaitement il faut récupérer la rente
énergétique qu'il y ait des
énergéticiens qu'ils puissent bénéficier
de prix extraordinairement élevés alors
même qu'ils n'ont fait ni
l'investissement ni prise de risque par
l'innovation ça c'est inacceptable donc
il est légitime de récupérer ces 30
c'est le mécanisme de marché qui
d'ailleurs existe en france que la
commission européenne propose et auquel
nous sommes favorables je précise
d'ailleurs que nous souhaitons que
toutes les énergies concernés soient
inclus dans ce mécanisme par exemple
aujourd'hui en france vous avez l'éolien
vous avez le solaire mais vous n'avez
pas l'hydraulique
maj hydraulique n'est pas dans le champ
de ce mécanisme je pense qu'il serait
bon de le mettre dedans c'est ce que
nous proposons ça rapportera 1 milliard
d'euros supplémentaires merci merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur maisonnée
du rassemble nationale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre l'actualité de ces dernières
semaines nous a placés face à un constat
les entreprises et les secteurs frappés
par la crise de l'énergie sont plus
nombreux et plus divers que ce que l'on
pouvait imaginer nous avons tous été
interpellés par le signal d'alarmé lancé
par par duralex qui a annoncé être
contraint de réduire sa production du
fait de l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie au point de mettre ses
salariés au chômage partiel la situation
de duralex est loin d'être isolé la
semaine dernière c'est la fonderie mais
castaing qui alerté sur l'augmentation
de ses coûts qui pourrait être multiplié
par quatre et qui poseraient un problème
évident de compétitivité et en prenant
du recul si l'hiver prochain s'annonce
rude de nombreuses entreprises notamment
celles dont les employés travaillent
dans des entrepôts auront beaucoup de
mal à chauffer leurs infrastructures ce
qui va poser un problème considérable de
conditions de travail
c'est évident l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie est un réel poids dans les
conséquences pèsent sur les emplois sur
les prix des produits est fatalement
pour les consommateurs qui la ressentent
déjà au quotidien sur ministre vous avez
mis en place une aide pour les
entreprises énergivores qui n'a pas été
satisfaisante vous l'avez reconnue vous
même vous en avez donc annoncer la
réforme mais c'est souvent le cas avec
vous c'est que ça n'est ni claire ni
anticiper vous êtes en a le sentiment
que vous êtes en permanence dans le
curatif nous discutons aujourd'hui en
commission alors que nous aurions pu
réunir notre assemblée pour prendre des
mesures sur l'énergie qui s'imposent
marine le pen réclamé l'ouverture d'une
session extraordinaire en septembre vous
préférez attendre le budget pour évoquer
ces questions soient à la mi-octobre
mois et demi de perdus alors ma question
sera toute simple est ce que est ce que
vous reconnaissez d'abord ce défaut
d'anticipation et pour être clair est ce
que ces entreprises vont devoir attendre
le projet de loi de finances 2010 23
pour connaître les contours de ce que
vous allez mettre en place pour leur
venir en aide ou bien êtes vous
aujourd'hui en capacité de nous annoncer
de nouvelles mesures précises et prenant
effet au plus tôt je remercie
monsieur maisonnée je coupe de secondes
le chrono pour vous dire juste que le
fait que nous n'ayons pas de session
extraordinaire
nous donne l'occasion d'avoir tout ce
cycle d'auditions de recevoir les
ministres et d'avoir des cycle
d'auditions sur l'énergie que nous
n'aurions probablement pas pu avoir si
nous avions eu une session
extraordinaire et donc je suis heureux
de vous voir et ça ne vous a pas échappé
et je suis très heureuse que vous soyez
présent et je vous pouvez transmettre à
madame le pen qu'elle est la bienvenue à
toutes les auditions également si elle
souhaite participer à ces travaux de
contrôle dans notre commission
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous
oui monsieur le député ont fait beaucoup
de reproches dans ma vie mais pas celui
de manquer de clarté on peut être
d'accord ou pas d'accord avec moi en
général ce que je dis est clair le
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
fait modifier sera modifié au 1er
octobre ce dispositif
supprimer la règle d'ebitda qui figurait
auparavant pour être remplacé par une
perte de bénéfices sur un mois pour
toutes les entreprises dont la facture
d'électricité ou de gaz représente plus
de 3 millions +2 3% du chiffre
d'affaires je peux être plus précis mais
il me semble que ce n'est déjà
suffisamment il s'agissant des états ou
intensif d'abord nous les soutenons
depuis des mois et vous avez cité un
certain nombre d'entreprises pourrait
citer le soutien que nous avons
apportées
arc international
ça me paraît plus efficace que la baisse
de tva que propose marine le pen qui ne
concerne pas les entreprises enfin sur
l'anticipation sur l'anticipation je
rappelle que nous sommes le seul état de
la zone euro à avoir mis en place un
bouclier tarifaires et des aides sur
l'énergie à partir d'octobre
2021 alors on peut nous reprocher de
dépenser trop on peut nous reprocher de
ne pas suffisamment ciblé dispositif à
tous les débats sont les bienvenus mais
nous reprocher de ne pas avoir anticipé
alors qu'aucun autre état n'est mis en
place un dispositif ça cela me paraît
infondée le résultat d'ailleurs je le
rappelle c'est que la moyenne
l'inflation la zone euro à cause des
prix de l'énergie et de 9 et 2 3% le
niveau d'inflation en france il de 5,3
c'est toujours trop élevé mais ces
quatre points de moins que la moyenne de
la zone euro merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame trouver du groupe
la france est soumise mal à me trouver
c'est à vous
bonjour merci monsieur le président est
monsieur le ministre donc on a appris
effectivement l'instant une augmentation
de 15% du gaz électricité en 2023 je dis
bien que nous l'apprenons parce que nous
n'avons pu participer malheureusement
aux discussions et aux décisions ce qui
peut interroger déjà depuis la
démocratie parlementaire maintenant j'en
arrive aux annonces 12 millions de
personnes en précarité énergétique à qui
nous allons verser un chèque enfin je
dis bien nous c'est les contribuables
nous allons verser des chèques de 20 de
pardon de 2 100 à 200 euros à ses 12
millions de personnes
il a été bien dit qu'il y aurait des
augmentations de facture par mois
de gaz de 25 euros électricité 20 euros
si si mes comptes sont juste ça veut
dire qu'il y aura plusieurs centaines
d'euros d'augmentation des factures
quand déjà on nous annonce un chèque en
une fois à 100 voire 200 euros pour ses
12 millions de personnes donc déjà le
compte n'y est pas ensuite ça ne
concernera pas évidemment les 20
millions d'autres ménages est encore
pire il ya certes une hausse maximale de
15 % des des prix du gaz électricité
mais qui ne concerne que 70 % des
ménages il ya 30 % des ménages qui passe
par des fournisseurs alternatifs et qui
eux devront subir encore bien davantage
l'explosion des prix et je ne parle pas
des collectivités locales que il me
semble qu'ils n'ont ils me semblent pas
été mentionnée je rappelle qu'il ya déjà
des piscines des gymnases etc qui sont
fermés du fait de l'explosion des coûts
qu'est-il prévu pour ces collectivités
locales nos enfants ou ont-ils apprendre
à nager dans les baignoires je ne sais
pas en tout cas nous n'avons pas de
piscine privée chauffée alors évidemment
nous nous avons une solution efficace
que vous remets vous refusez de mettre
en oeuvre mais qui existait avant qui
s'appelle le tarif unique réglementée
notamment de l'électricité avant je dis
bien comme avant avant que ne soit
dérégulé et libéraliser les marchés de
l'énergie vous savez que c'est faisable
aussi avec un prix raisonnable pour les
de l'électricité pour l'ensemble des
fournisseurs donc sa demande en fait de
remettre en cause la mécanique et c'est
bien là le problème du marché européen
notamment de l'électricité ou du gaz et
ce qui n'empêchera absolument pas
d'ailleurs la solidarité les échanges
contrairement à ce qui nous est dit donc
que ce soit la puissance publique qui
pilote les prix de chaque source
d'énergie en fonction des coûts de
production ce n'est pas ce que propose
la commission européenne aujourd'hui
qu'ils proposent mende plafonné à terme
à un niveau très élevé en réalité les
lecteurs le prix d'électricité et ce
certainement pas d'ailleurs celui du gaz
je dirais par ailleurs que si nous en
sommes dans cette situation c'est que
nous pâtissons aussi et bien je dirais
de tous vos choix néolibéraux depuis
cinq ans avec un très grave déficit
d'investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables avec un gouvernement un
état qui n'atteint pas les objectifs
qu'il s'est lui même fixée la rénovation
thermique des logements nous sommes là
aussi très loin des objectifs fixés et
dans les transports publics noté vous
faire des comparaisons avec les pays
européens et bien moi je pourrais vous
citer l'espagne ou l'allemagne où là on
a d une politique publique actifs
justement pour pour en baisser les prix
ce qui est je finirai là dessus et bien
malheureusement amènera sans doute à une
sobriété certes nécessaire mais qui sera
juste une précision coupé 2 2 secondes
le chrono le le nom micro fonctionne
très bien ce qui fait que vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous rapprocher trop près
du micro quel que soit voilà on entend
très bien et il n'y a pas besoin de s'en
rapprocher trop je me permets de le
préciser c'est tout je me permets
simplement de préciser cet aspect
technique monsieur vous pouvez relancer
le coeur lancé le chrono
oui madame la députée moi je suis
toujours surpris de voir la france
insoumise prendre systématiquement en
exemple des modèles plus libéraux que le
nôtre un jour c'est monsieur rufin avec
la grande bretagne aujourd'hui c'est
l'allemagne qui essaie de rattraper
aujourd'hui des dépenses que nous nous
avons fait de manière totalement dissipé
moi je préfère le modèle protecteur de
la france aux autres modèles européens
qui ont moins réagi et moins tôt à la
crise énergétique que ne l'a fait la
france quant à se faire accuser
néolibéralisme quand on dépense plus de
17 milliards d'euros pour protéger des
français je vous dire que ça ne manque
pas de sel il n'y a que la france
insoumise pour imaginer des phrases
pareil le bouclier tarifaire par
ailleurs je vous le précise parce que
c'est bien aussi de dire de la vérité
plutôt que des mensonges des
approximations touche tous les français
y compris ceux qui sont chez les
fournisseurs alternatifs la protection
aux protège par définition ceux qui ont
le plus besoin 200 euros de chèques ou
100 euros c'est une somme qui n'est pas
négligeable elle représente 1,8 milliard
d'euros de financements publics enfin
les collectivités locales sont protégés
puisque 30 pile d'entre elles je leur ai
elles ont accès à un tarif régulé et les
autres mais déficit d'un demi milliard
d'euros qui ont été votées vous l'avez
sans doute oublié par le parlement cet
été merci messieurs ministre messieurs
vigier pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous le savez cette rentrée
2022 est particulière et bien des égards
et inquiète de nombreux français partout
sur le territoire national dans ce
contexte les réformes structurelles
doivent être urgemment menées elles
doivent être couplé au besoin d'aidé
justement et dignement les français ont
nécessité vous le savez l'enjeu
énergétique est bien évidemment centrale
dans ce cadre une réforme du marché
intérieur et vous en avez parlé de
l'énergie semble être une nécessité
en effet nous sommes aujourd'hui obligés
d'acheter notre électricité sur le
marché de gros a un coût marginal qui
est en réalité celui du gaz le prédit
qu' libre en europe étant calculée sur
le coût de fonctionnement des moyens de
production les plus onéreux ce qui est
le cas des centrales à gaz pourtant vous
le savez très bien et vous pousser dans
le sens cela grâce au nucléaire la
france produit une électricité moins
chère est décarbonée garantissant une
part importante de notre souveraineté
énergétique et qu'il faut plus que
jamais développé la situation est
d'autant plus critique qu avec la crise
actuelle comme vous le savez nos
entreprises voient leur facture
augmenter de 600 à 700 % comme l'ont
signalé plusieurs entrepreneurs de mon
département cette situation n'est pas
viable il en va directement de la survie
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs
économiques notamment sur les
territoires ruraux vous allez prolonger
le bouclier tarifaire limitant la
voulait des prix de l'énergie et c'est
une bonne chose je le dis clairement
mais jusqu'à quand jusqu à la volée des
prix idem pour le carburant jusqu'à
quand vous allez aussi aider les
entreprises vous l'avez dit sur le choc
budgétaire que représentent les dépenses
énergétiques en fonction des critères
que vous avez cités cependant monsieur
ministre des entreprises passent dans
les mailles du filet que faire pour
celle ci est troisième point enfin que
sera l'action de la france afin
d'envisager une réforme du marché
intérieur de l'énergie je vous remercie
merci messieurs ministre
bien je confirme monsieur vigier que
nous sommes favorables un découplage
total dans le marché européen de
l'énergie entre les prix du gaz et les
prix de l'électricité était notre
objectif est de parvenir un découplage
total et définitif ça fait un an qu'on
nous le réclamons les choses bougent
dans le bon sens puisque la commission
européenne s'est prononcée en faveur que
l'allemagne après l'avoir refusé pendant
plusieurs mois s'est prononcé en faveur
dont nous sommes dans la bonne direction
comme cela prendra du temps nous sommes
aussi favorables à des mesures
temporaires de type subventions des
centrales à gaz de façon à rapprocher
les prix du gaz et de l'électricité et
du coup avoir des prix d'électricité
qu'ils soient moins élevés
s'agissant de bouclier énergétique tant
que nous avons des prix qui flambent
nous maintenons un bouclier tarifaire
pour les ménages parce que notre
objectif est d'absorber le choc
inflationniste pour les ménages et quand
je regarde aujourd'hui je sais bien que
pour des millions de nos compatriotes la
situation est dure mais nous protégeons
mieux le pouvoir d'achat de nos
compatriotes que le font beaucoup
d'autres pays européens et je pense que
c'est la bonne politique nous la
maintiendrons tant que les prix de
l'énergie continueront à flamber
s'agissant des carburants nous avons
toujours prévu une remise qui diminuera
jusqu'à décembre 2022 donc décembre de
cette année nous verrons après nous
sommes en janvier nous notre évaluation
et que les prix du baril se
maintiendront entre 85 et 100 dollars
donc on devrait revenir à des niveaux de
tarifs qui soit raisonnable après si
jamais on devait avoir à nouveau des
prix du baril qui flambent nous
pourrions remettre en place un
dispositif ciblé sur ceux qui sont
obligés de prendre leur voiture pour se
déplacer
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur martineau du modem
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre collègues je vous remercie
vivement pour votre présence ce jour
devant notre commission je souhaite vous
interroger sur deux sujets précisément
tout d'abord concernant le budget de
l'état que nous nous apprêtons à
examiner vous avez indiqué que le shaq
alimentaire n'y seraient pas présents se
disputent ce dispositif est pourtant à
levier de soutien des plus modestes afin
de leur permettre d'acheter des produits
frais et locaux nous soutenons
particulièrement cet outil
rappelons qu'il est également qu'il
s'agit d'une idée proposée par la
convention citoyenne
le climat est que son principe avait été
inscrit dans le cadre de la loire
éthylique lima résilience en outre en
tant qu'agriculteur et pomiculteurs je
me sens particulièrement concernés par
cette mesure que je considère d'utilité
publique pouvez vous nous confirmer que
cette idée n'est pas enterrée et si vous
pouvez nous expliquer les raisons de ce
report par ailleurs je change ma
question parce que vous avez répondu sur
les énergies renouvelables mais sur un
autre sujet les associations
propriétaires de patrimoine classé en
rénovation avec le soutien de l'aide cas
via le loto du patrimoine par exemple
comme la retourne ferroviaire à montabon
se retrouvent pénalisés taxé sur les
taxes foncières suite à ces rénovations
mettant en danger ces associations
pourriez-vous pourrions nous trouver une
solution commun celle des valeurs
foncières pour ne pas compromettre les
actions de rénovation de ce patrimoine
culturel est commun je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre
alors la deuxième question c'est la
colle et il y en a toujours une dans une
audition donc bravo
donc on vous apportera les éléments de
réponse par écrit par l'intermédiaire de
mon cabinet mais je dois dire que je
n'étais pas au courant de cette
difficulté là s'agissant de chèques
alimentaires nous avons beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé dessus il est très
honnêtement nous ne sommes pas parvenus
à une solution satisfaisante c'est une
solution qui ne reviennent pas financées
sur l'argent du contribuable les
importations de produits alimentaires et
ça c'est évidemment un dispositif auquel
je me poserai toujours l'argent du
contribuable doit pas être utilisé pour
payer de nouvelles importations de
produits alimentaires mais bien au
contraire pour soutenir une alimentation
saine à partir de produits agricoles
français et nous ne sommes pas arrivés à
construire ce dispositif donc nous avons
mis en place une allocation
exceptionnelle de rentrer de 100 euros
auxquels s'ajoutent 2 50 euros par
enfant mais je vous confirme que nous
continuons à travailler sur ce
dispositif pour essayer de trouver une
solution qui permette de conjuguer
soutien aux ménages et soutient
l'agriculture française
bien vous avez parfait on est dans les
temps donc tout va bien monsieur potier
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
l'heure est grave sur le plan social et
économique
et donc c'est le moment de faire preuve
de modération dans cette modération moi
je vais me réjouir profondément que vous
ayez donné une définition des super
profits au medef vous avez dit que vous
ne saviez pas trop ce que c'était celle
que vous venez de formuler me semble
assez convenable
d'autres désaccords elle va porter sur
l'échelle et la temporalité
vous en faisant remettant une
proposition européenne qui est heureuse
vous nous reporter de six mois un an
deux ans peut-être aux calendes grecques
or il ya une urgence à équilibrer le
budget de la nation et à faire
participer ce qui de façon indue ont
profité de cette crise à ceux qui
aujourd'hui sur la ligne de flottaison
du pouvoir d'achat n'en peuvent plus
mais et qui ne seront pas consolé par
les seules aides que vous avez énuméré
aujourd'hui
alors que les super profits c'est un
sujet national est immédiat je dis au
nom du groupe socialiste est pas un
c'est certes une perspective européenne
mais un ne doit pas empêcher l'autre la
deuxième remarque va à une attention
bienveillante parce que à ce moment là
on peut être confiant dans les
dispositifs que vous annoncez sur toutes
les mailles que vient d'évoquer le
collègue jean-pierre vigier à des
entreprises qui sont pas peut-être dans
le radar aujourd'hui il ya des ménages
je pense au cou du pellet qui
aujourd'hui un sujet populaire social
qui est en train de monter très fort
c'était un peu l'énergie renouvelable
accessible aux plus modestes d'entre
nous est un rendez vous qui peut être
fatale pour le budget de six verres donc
est-ce que vous êtes très un dialogue
fin passe toujours sur une surenchère à
mai à trouver des solutions qui ne
laisse pas des personnes au bord du
chemin enfin la dernière question est
plus générique monsieur bruno le bain
elle se dit que c'est une réflexion
pourrait que on y participe aujourd'hui
il y aura d'autres moments de débats
dans le plf on est confronté au soutien
nos actifs stratégiques de notre
économie on est confronté à maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat le compte n'y est pas
mais ça va dans le sens là de nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles et on doit
en même temps engagée l'immense chantier
de la décarbonation de l'aménagement du
territoire et de la modernisation de
notre pays pour qu'ils soient plus
résilient par rapport aux crises au long
cours qui s'annonce celle du dérèglement
climatique
cette équation là elle suppose un
nouveau partage de la valeur une
nouvelle échelle des salaires une
fiscalité plus juste
merci monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur gautier je vous confirme
que
reprend les propos que j'ai eu nous ne
voulons ni rente ni de taxation de
toutes les entreprises françaises et
c'est dans cette voie là que nous
apportons notre soutien aux propositions
qui sont faites par la commission
européenne je renvoie d'ailleurs je suis
pas à prix nobel d'économie mais je lis
les prix nobel d'économie dont vous
verrez dans l'interview que des gentils
roll au point il ya quelques jours que
lui-même dit qu'il ne sait pas ce que
c'est que les super profits donc je
partage l'avis d'un prix nobel
d'économie je sais très bien ce qu'est
une rente et c'est contre les rentes que
nous nous battons et il y avait
effectivement une rente énergétique et
cette rente énergétique n'est pas
acceptable taire toutes ces entreprises
qui vont bénéficier de bénéfices
considérables alors même qu'elles n'ont
pas spécialement investi ou pas
spécialement pris de risques que vous
qu'elles redonnent cette rente chose
entreprises pétrolières des entreprises
énergéticienne qui font du renouvelable
elles doivent redonner le produit de
cette rente à la collectivité pour aider
les ménages et les entreprises à passer
ce moment difficile c'est ça me paraît
juste et nécessaire sur le peuple et je
partage totalement votre avis là je me
sont remontés à chaque fois que je me
déplace donc nous sommes favorables à ce
qu' il y ait une aide spécifique sur le
peuple et pour tout ce qu'on fait ce
choix là qui est un choix judicieux
d'ailleurs du point de vue
environnemental
quant à l'idée d'avoir un modèle là
capitalistique plus juste bien entendu
bientôt je suis favorable au
développement de l'intéressement de la
participation de meilleure association
des salariés et à une fiscalité plus
juste qui passe c'est la question que
pose et paul midy par la mise en place
le plus rapidement possible d'une
fiscalité minimale à l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour qui n'est pas l'évasion
fiscale pas d'optimisation fiscale j'ai
pris l'initiative à semaine dernière
parce que les travaux ont commencé à
patiner au niveau européen de relance et
a5 avec l'italie l'allemagne et
l'espagne la mise en place de cette
fiscalité minimale à l'iss merci
monsieur le ministre la parole et à
monsieur lamiraux pour le groupe horizon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais tout d'abord vous
remercier pour toutes les précisions
vous avez apporté sur les dispositifs
dead pour la luttre compte les
augmentations de l'énergie vous dire que
vous avez annoncé qu'il y aurait des
modifications les améliorations d'ici la
fin de l'année pour ma part j'ai une
grande préférence pour une aide pour les
grands rouleurs et ceux qui prennent
leur voiture pour aller travailler qu'on
puisse favoriser le travail par rapport
à d'autres modes de circulation ou
d'autres utilisations de sa voiture vous
le savez peut-être gt1 le l'origine de
la création d'une association pôle
pharma qui avait pour vocation il ya
toujours pour vocation de mettre en
valeur et de fédérer les entreprises de
la filière pharma et surtout les
producteurs de médicaments et les
producteurs de dispositifs médicaux et
donc c'est dans ce domaine que je
souhaiterais vous poser des questions
d'abord vous demander si vous croyez
qu'il sera possible un jour d'améliorer
notre politique globale nationale du
médicament et surtout de la production
en france de médicaments car nos
industriels sont basculer entre
différents ministères
de fixation de prix à aide à le à la
production et tout ça pose quelques
problèmes et fait qu'il y a encore des
productions qui s'en vont à l'étranger
donc est ce qui est ce que votre
ministère un jour pourrait prendre le
lead sur cette production est sûre cette
politique de santé
le deuxième point que je voulais évoquer
aussi sur la santé il y à une sorte
d'impôt qui ne dépend pas de votre
ministère mais qui est aussi un impôt
c'est la clause de sauvegarde
c'est un impôt difficile à comprendre
les industriels qui est peu connu mais
qui en gros permet à l'état de récupérer
ce qui est dépensé au dessus de l'ondam
que nous votons et qui fait que les
entreprises
j'irai 10 ou 12 - après avoir dépensé
effet leur chiffre d'affaires se voit
redonner à l'état une partie de leur
chiffre d'affaires et ce même pour les
entreprises qui fabriquent des
médicaments ou des dispositifs médicaux
qui font gagner de l'argent au système
de santé je parle des génériques ou d
différents dispositifs médicaux ça me
semble profondément injuste que ce
qu'ils font gagner de l'argent au
système de santé et aussi à participer à
l'effort national
j'ai ministre
ou bien notés sur les gros rouleurs
monsieur miro je partage partage ce
sentiment surtout ceux qui n'ont pas
d'autre choix pour elle travaille et se
rendre sur un lieu de travail leur usine
entreprises de leur administration que
de prendre leur véhicule
s'agissant du prix du médicament je
pense que je créerai la révolution si
j'annonçais bercy va prendre le lead sur
ce sujet éminemment sensible je dis
simplement que le présent la république
est parfaitement conscient de sujets que
nous traitons depuis plusieurs années
notamment en accélérant les
autorisations de mise en marché d'un
point absolument clé pour l'industrie du
médicament
nous importons aussi beaucoup de nos
médicaments notamment des génériques
donc je pense qu'il faut être prudent
sur la suppression de la clause de
sauvegarde en revanche travailler sur
tous les dispositifs permettront
d'accélérer la recherche et le
développement en matière de médicaments
en france je pense que c'est absolument
essentiel il ya un vrai risque sinon de
voir notre industrie pharmaceutique
perdre son leadership nous avons dans
france 2030 consacrer des moyens très
importants à la production en
particulier dans le domaine de la santé
nous avons déjà les premiers résultats
sur le paracétamol je pense qu'il faut
continuer à avancer dans cette direction
là et je partage votre évaluation c'est
un enjeu absolument stratégique pour
notre pays
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
fournier pour le groupe écologiste merci
monsieur monsieur le ministre alors
j'avais la même question sur le sur le
chèque alimentaire je regrette que
l'arbitrage qui soit rendue soit des
deux défavorable je pense que c'est une
mesure importante qui étaient
importantes maintenant qui était
importante aussi pour les agriculteurs
et notamment si on y intégrer une
dimension qualité important pour les
agriculteurs bio qui souffrent beaucoup
dans la période et vous le savez est
donc je regrette et j'espère que
ministre marc fesneau saura convaincre
et trouver le bon dispositif pour
répondre à ce sujet mais mon propos
portera principalement sur les
collectivités vous ne l'avez pas évoquée
dans votre introduction vous avez un peu
répondu
ma collègue peut-être parce que vous
considérez que les collectivités sont en
bonne santé et financière et moi je vous
le dit la situation est plus
qu'alarmante pour les collectivités vous
ai répondu qu'il y avait des réponses
pour toutes les collectivités vous savez
que c'est pas vrai il y en a pour les
très petites collectivités le demi
million donc 2000 milliards pardon vous
avez évoqué et quand même issue vous le
savez du travail parlementaire mais il
est nettement insuffisant par rapport à
la situation que peuvent vivre les
collectivités avec une inflation du prix
d'énergie mais aussi des produits
alimentaires et sade et concernent en
direct mais aussi à l'augmentation du
prix de l' indice des fonctionnaires
nécessaires mais qui a un impact sur les
collectivités je vous donne l'exemple de
la ville où je suis élue tour où on va
on va passer sur la facture énergétique
d'une facture de 4 millions d'euros en
2019 à plus de 10 millions en 2023 c'est
une explosion et vos amis de la majorité
critiquent le maire qui fait un choix
d'augmenter le seul impôt sur lesquels
il a un peu de maîtrise la taxe foncière
pour avoir un peu de capacité
d'investissement pour répondre aux
enjeux de la transition écologique et je
vous le dis les collectivités se
retrouve dans une situation qui rend
impossible la plupart des
investissements elles voient leurs
dépenses de fonctionnement explosé et
elles sont dans une situation complexe l
on fasse à sa dé des réponses qui sont
évoqués j'aimerais vous poser une
question sur le fond vert dont on entend
beaucoup parler qui
au-delà d'être nettement insuffisant un
milliard et demi
d'annoncé et si on en suit ce que dit
les l'iccat cec c'est plus de 10
milliards d'euros qu'il faudrait
immédiatement pour soutenir
l'investissement dans les collectivités
en faveur de la transition écologique
alors ce fonds quel en sera le les
modalités on comprend déjà qu'il va
recycler une partie de la des cils et
que sur les 1 milliard et demi il y aura
au moins six cents 600 millions qui
viendront d'un recyclage de crédits
c'est une habitude on connaît ces
situations là mais de quelle manière
comptez vous aider les collectivités
peut-on
indexer la dotation sur sur l'inflation
peut-on imaginer
clie tarifaire pour l'ensemble des
collectivités qui soit efficace et qui
puisse les accompagner dans leurs
responsabilités monsieur le ministre
oui d'abord je vous redis ce chèque
alimentaire que la porte n'est
absolument pas fermé je dis seulement
que nous sommes pas parvenus à un
dispositif qui soit à la fois bon pour
les ménages est bon pour notre
agriculture moi je peux pas expliquer
aux contribuables que je prendre son
argent pour payer des produits
alimentaires qui sont réalisées hors
d'europe à bas prix donc là dessus non
mais c'est compliqué je suis prêt à en
débattre ça fait deux ans que nous
travaillons dessus donc je suis prêt à
prendre tout le temps nécessaire pour
vous expliquer les blocages techniques
auxquelles nous faisons face et blocage
juridique auquel nous faisons face
s'agissant des collectivités locales moi
je ne mésestime pas du tout les
difficultés des collectivités locales il
dit simplement que les situations sont
extrêmement disparates vous avez des
collectivités qui s'en sortent bien
certaine qu'on des recettes fiscales de
dmt ou qui sont fortes d'autres qui sont
en grande difficulté pas les traiter
toutes de la même façon vous avez aussi
permettez moi de vous le dire des
collectivités qui sont bien gérées et
d'autres ils sont moins bien gérés moi
quand je vois des collectivités qui ont
embauché massivement et qui viennent
ensuite demandé à l'état parce qu'elles
ne peuvent pas faire face à des factures
énergétiques de payer à la place des
collectivités ça peut poser une
difficulté et je pense qu'il est bon là
aussi vis-à-vis du contribuable de
s'assurer de la responsabilité et du
sens des responsabilités des
collectivités locales dans ce cadre là
nous sommes prêts à aider toutes celles
qui font face à des difficultés majeures
qui ont bien géré et qui n'ont aucune
raison de payer pour la crise
énergétique actuelle c'est juste le
cadre que je fixe et je rappelle que les
470 millions d'euros que nous avons
votée ça n'est pas rien ça concerne plus
de 18000 communes toutes celles qui ont
fixé un temps de critères qui sont très
clairs notamment sur la caf tout ça doit
nous permettre d'aider les collectivités
locales qui en ont le plus besoin et qui
ont fait preuve de sens des
responsabilités dans le passé merci
monsieur le ministre giovanni williams
pour le groupe gdr
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre cher collègue monsieur le
ministre nous avons été alertés suite à
l'annoncé faite de la suppression de la
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises en 2023 puis 2024
concrètement c'est une perte si on prend
un exemple de la communauté
d'agglomération du centre de la
martinique d'environ 10 millions 230 8
796 euros à l'échelle d'un territoire
insulaire
cela veut dire fragiliser durablement
les collectivités et leur trésorerie
monsieur ministre et au regard de ce
constat et des conséquences engendrées
pour nos collectivités pouvez vous nous
préciser les modalités de compensation
si elle existe merci
monsieur le ministre
est-ce qu'il faut continuer à baisser
les impôts de production moi ma réponse
est trois fois oui peut être en
désaccord mais comme notre objectif
c'est la l'industrialisation du pays et
que vous n'aurez un disque à liserés pas
avec des impôts de production qui reste
cinq ou six fois plus élevé que nos
voisins allemands ou européens je
persiste et je signe il faut continuer à
baisser les impôts de production en
deuxième lieu nous le faisons de manière
responsable nous voyons bien les
contraintes sur les finances publiques
dont nous le faisons en deux fois parce
qu'il faut tenir nos objectifs de
finances publiques et de réduction des
déficits
troisième principe il faut compenser des
collectivités locales ils s'arment je
vous invite à participer au dialogue sur
ce sujet là pour que nous trouvions les
meilleures compensations et c'est quoi
les meilleures compensations c'est pas
uniquement de compenser à l'euro près
les pertes de recettes fiscales pour les
collectivités c'est aussi s'assurer
qu'elles ont une incitation à faire
venir des entreprises l'activité
économique et des usines sur leur
territoire et c'est ça qui est le plus
difficile aujourd'hui mais moi je suis
prêt à voir cette discussion il faut que
nous trouvions un moyen d'inciter les
entreprises à accueillir de l'activité
que de mixeur un territoire dont les
collectivités ne perdront pas ce dont
nous nous devons nous assurer ces
quelques restes inciter à développer
l'activité économique soit territoire je
vous invite à vous joindre à la
discussion sur ce sujet
monsieur william comme il restait du
temps vous avez quelque chose à dire
c'est bon très bien monsieur molac pour
le groupe fiat
oui merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre donc effectivement j'avais une
question aussi sur la cvae parce que
nous nous sommes plutôt pour l'autonomie
fiscale des collectivités locales qui
est réduite à pas grand-chose comme
vient de le dire le collègue écologiste
et donc la suppression de la cvae
alors quelles compensations j'ai vu que
vous n'aviez pas de questions claires
enfin de réponse claire avec l'idée de
garder un lien entre la collectivité
enfants ou les collectivités et
l'activité économique ça me parait
effectivement st donc je me demande
pourquoi finalement modifié la cvae dans
ce cas là mais bon donc il faudra
absolument qu'on en discute je vois
aussi que on avait beaucoup parlé
effectivement d'une surtaxe alors sur
les super bénéfices ou sur les la rente
fin peu importe je crois qu'elle est il
est nécessaire effectivement de dit pas
c est le plus rapidement possible parce
que c'est quelque chose qui chez moi en
tout cas dans les endroits où je suis
passé ce n'est pas passé inaperçu auprès
de la plupart des concitoyens
sur les carburants puisque j'ai vu que
sur l'électricité sur le gaz etc vous
avez des propositions qui vont plutôt
dans une une augmentation c'est bienvenu
sur le carburant
je pense que la ristourne actuelle ne
donne pas satisfaction à la mesure je ne
trouve pas assez ciblées je pense que
par exemple les députés n'ont pas besoin
d'avoir une remise de 15 centimes sur le
sur le gasoil par exemple ou sur
l'essence donc
voilà je le jeu le dit alors donc comme
je sais que ça va changer à partir de
décembre pour le janvier 2023 je crois
qu'il faut l'axé sur ceux qui vraiment
sont des gros rouleurs d'une part et
d'autre part évidemment il ya une
question de social c'est-à-dire pour les
plus faibles
voilà et juste pour terminer si j'ai
encore un petit peu de temps vous
l'écoutez les réponses non mais si vous
voulez continuer vous avez donc c'est
pas grave je verrai ça directement être
le ministre après ses implications
détails très bien monsieur le ministre
un confessionnal a dit sue delà de
l'audition
je vous confirme en tout cas sur la cvae
notre objectif est bien de créer un lien
entre l'activité économique et la
rémunération pour les collectivités
locales à vous dites que je n'ai pas de
solution toute faite si j'étais arrivé
qu'une solution toute faite vous ne
voyez reproché aussi que j'apporte une
solution toute faite et on dit il n'ya
pas de dialogue et que j'apporte pas de
solution on me dit a pas de solution
c'est dommage donc dans tous les cas le
ministre est perdant je crois que ça
fait partie des fonctions en tout cas je
vous invite vous aussi au dialogue sur
ce sujet là sur la remise carburant ben
je rappelle juste que cette majorité
avait proposé une remise ciblés nous a
dit que c'était trop compliqué que c'est
une usine à gaz donc nous avons laissé
sa chance au dialogue au compromis je
pense pour vous dire le fond de ma
pensée que dans cette rentrée qui est
très difficile pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes notamment sur les prix
alimentaires avec une transmission des
prix de gros au prix de détail avoir une
remise qui concerne tout le monde y
compris des retraités compris les
retraités des zones rurales après tout
c'est amorti le choc de la rentrée et
c'est pas une mauvaise chose ensuite sur
la durée plus longue je pense qu'il est
indispensable effectivement quoi qu'il
arrive de cible et il faut encore
uniquement si les prix du carburant
repartent à la hausse sinon c'est pas la
peine de subventionner des énergies
fossiles mais si jamais ça devait être
le cas je pense qu'effectivement
dispositif ciblé serait hautement
préférable
merci monsieur le ministre nous avons
terminé avec les orateurs de groupe ce
que je vous propose c'est passé dans une
nouvelle séquence où je vais prendre
toutes les questions individuelles en
revanche le timing light intransigeant à
une minute 0 0 je couple nous allons
commencer donc n'hésitez pas à lever la
main et je suis avec thierry qui notent
les demandes de prise de parole nous
commençons tout de suite avec damien
adam c'est à vous
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre d'être
là et merci 1 pour votre réactivité face
à ces crises énergétiques depuis le mois
d'octobre 2000 21 on le rappellera
jamais assez le gouvernement français et
la majorité ont agi dès octobre 2021 sur
le sujet et surtout davo de présence dès
aujourd'hui dès cet après-midi alors
même que la conférence de presse vient
tout juste de se terminer
à propos du coût du plan global pour le
annoncées par le gouvernement cet après
midi vous avez indiqué que ce serait
autour de 50 milliards bruts 16
milliards nets une fois retranché les
sur 7 des élèves des énergéticiens
pouvez vous nous indiquer sur quel
scénario de prix ce coût a été établi et
quel impact sud eux en cas de baisse ou
de hausse des prix de l'énergie je
voudrais également parlé du chèque
énergie vous avez annoncé la mise en
place d'un chèque énergie exceptionnelle
qui va toucher 12 millions de ménages
soit 40 % d'entre eux lors de la
conférence de presse il a été donné deux
exemples de ménages éligibles mais
uniquement avec des enfants couples ou
célibataires pouvez vous pour bien
comprendre le public cible pourriez vous
nous indiquez le revenu fiscal de
référence pour une personne seule sans
enfant soit éligible je vous remercie
beaucoup monsieur tivoli
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre notre pays a souffert ces 40
dernières années d'un mouvement de
désindustrialisation avec un recul de
l'emploi industriel un recul de la
contribution de ce secteur au pib et une
forte croissance du secteur des services
marchands les causes structurelles et
conjoncturelles du fait de
l'externalisation croissante de
certaines tâches de l'industrie vers le
secteur des services d'une demande qui
s'est asséchée du fait d'un dumping
social déloyale et de délocalisation
d'irresponsables bref notre industrie a
souffert d'une perte de compétitivité
internationale on parle souvent du
couple franco-allemand se compare
souvent d'autres pays et si je me réfère
aux données de l'insee de 2020 quand
l'allemagne avait en 2000 une valeur
ajoutée de l'ordre de 4 186 milliards
d'euros constants la france en avait 250
milliards mais ce qui est dramatique
c'est qu'en 2018 cette part de la valeur
ajoutée est passée à 766 milliards pour
l'allemagne alors que pour la france
elle n'est qu'à peine 2 280 milliards
alors du sabordage de notre secteur
nucléaire et cette odieuse proposition
de monsieur macron d'aidé l'allemagne
sur le plan énergétique
comment allez vous redresser la barre
sur le plan industriel je vous remercie
monsieur léné hop et les filles
monsieur le ministre bonjour début août
je vous ai adressé une question écrite
sur à propos de la nationalisation vous
avez d'edf et notamment sur le statut de
cette entreprise est ce qu'elle va
rester une société anonyme ou est ce
qu'elle va devenir un établissement
public à caractère industriel et
commercial
mais cette question n'a de sens que dans
le cadre de la sortie du marché vous
n'avez pas répondu à la question ma
collègue aurélie trouvé tout à l'heure
le marché on envoie tout un tas de
problèmes tout à l'heure le président de
rte nous indiquait par exemple que le
prix de gros à l'heure actuelle est deux
à trois fois supérieurs aux risques
raisonnablement anticipable je ne prends
que cet exemple là pour montrer les
défaillances du marché à l'heure
actuelle ne pensez vous pas qu'il est
temps de construire un grand pôle public
de l'électricité et du gaz ça
permettrait une rationalisation de la
planification et donc son efficacité et
dé prix basé sur les coûts de production
avec donc des tarifs abordables et une
visibilité pour tous les acteurs y
compris les entreprises qui souhaitent
décarbonés leur production merci
messieurs marchive renaissance
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure l'envolée des prix de l'énergie
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
impacte lourdement les entreprises
françaises je tiens aussi à saluer le
dispositif de soutien qui a été mis en
place en juillet que vous avez récemment
assoupli et pour prolonger jusqu'à la
fin de l'année ainsi que les efforts
français pour aboutir à une solution
coordonnés à l'échelle européenne
alors qu'elles doivent procéder d'ici la
mi-décembre renouvellement de leurs
contrats d'approvisionnement pour les
années à venir nombreux sont les
entreprises qui formulent aujourd'hui le
besoin d'une visibilité à plus long
terme les cours de l'énergie pour les
années 2000 23 2024 tout en effet
prohibitifs et ne leur permettent pas de
s'engager aux tarifs proposés allant
même parfois jusqu'à remettre en
question leur capacité à résister à la
crise que nous traversons dans ce
contexte incertain de hausse des coûts
et de raréfaction de l'énergie où chacun
cherche les solutions qui permettront
d'aboutir à la sobriété énergétique je
me permets donc monsieur le ministre de
vous interroger concernant
l'accompagnement de nos entreprises à
partir de 2023 ainsi que les prochaines
étapes de négociation aux rockies ni
devant permettre d'envisager une merci
monsieur des gars et les filles
monsieur le ministre comme nous savons
tous le transporteur maritime cma-cgm
réalise des superprofits 14,8 milliards
de dollars sur les six premiers mois de
2000 22 après les 18 milliards engrangés
en 2021 par ailleurs cma-cgm a réduit
les fréquences de rotation de ses
bateaux est multiplié par quatre quand
ce n'est pas par 10 le coût du fret de
certaines denrées à la réunion même si
elle affirme le contraire et se vante
d'avoir fait baisser les prix il est
facile de faire un geste qu'on fait de
tels profits de plus la cma-cgm est
pratiquement en situation de monopole à
la réunion actionnaire principal de la
société d'acconage et de manutention et
de la c est ma terminale nous ne sommes
pas loin d'un trust monsieur le ministre
que comptez vous faire pour assurer
d'une part la sécurité de la desserte de
la réunion et d'autre part qu'elle se
fasse dans des conditions satisfaisantes
en termes de coûts êtes vous prêt à
taxer les super profits réalisés sur le
dos des réunionnaises et des réunionnais
sans inat dynastie initiative forte de
l'état de très nombreuses entreprises
seront faillite et de des milliers de
familles connaîtront à ma progression un
appauvrissement considérable beaucoup
madame bajon renaissance
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre présence
aujourd'hui ma question fait suite aux
auditions menées précédemment on a reçu
jean bernard lévy pour edf et xavier
pied choisi pour rte et hong hao
constater comme vous le savez que le
productible nucléaire a décliné depuis
plusieurs années et sera comprise entre
eux probablement 310 a340 térawatts
seulement l'année prochaine outre les
tensions engendrées sur le réseau il ya
aussi un vrai impact sur la
compétitivité de la france à l'heure où
on parle de réindustrialisation ma
question est donc une question un peu
ouverte sur votre vision de la situation
de la façon dont ce secteur que vous je
sais je crois savoir chérissez
particulièrement peut être remontée dans
les années à venir et quelle place aura
la future gouvernance d'edf dans ce
cadre merci madame bateau écologiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de questions la première les
ménages qui sont aux tarifs réglementés
du gaz sur lequel s'appuie le bouclier
tarifaires ont reçu au mois de mai un
courrier qui les informe de la
suppression des tarifs réglementés au 30
juin 2000 23 c'est l'application de
l'article 63 de la loi de 2019 est ce
que vous allez remettre en cause cette
suppression du tarif réglementé du gaz
pour pouvoir à l'avenir maintenir un
bouclier tarifaire deuxième question sur
les collectivités les entreprises
monsieur le ministre pardon dans le
prolongement de ce qu'a dit mon collègue
des deux sèvres ce n'est sans doute pas
un hasard mais vous n'y êtes pas du tout
c'est à dire qu'en fait le problème
actuel pour les entreprises et les
collectivités
c'est que leur contrat de fourniture
d'électricité prenne fin et qu'elle se
retrouve avec des offres absolument
délirante qu'elles ne peuvent pas
souscrire exemple une entreprise qui a
huit cent mille euros de facture
d'électricité qui se voit proposer une
offre à 17 millions d'euros et donc la
demande des collectivités comme des
entreprises c'est qu'il y ait d'une
façon ou d'une autre non pas une aide
ponctuelle en fait de l'état mais qu'il
y ait un tarif réglementé pour les
collectivités et un tarif réglementé
pour les entreprises beaucoup monsieur
bothorel renaissance merci monsieur le
président messieurs lui d'abord bravo
pour les annonceurs sur le chlore de
lundi on va continuer dans les
anglicismes d'arc store quid commerce
des anglicismes pour désigner des
entrepôts des magasins il ya débat
autour de salive rend rapidement des
produits alimentaires et qui surgissent
dans le paysage de plusieurs villes en
la promesse client c'est la rapidité de
livraison le prix donc le pouvoir
d'achat soyez pas étonné que je pose
cette question dans le cadre de cette
audition elle est simple la question
cette activité est-elle selon vous
bienvenue ou faut-il selon vous contre
ar son développement et puis comme il me
reste beaucoup de temps et que vous êtes
responsable de pouce qui va pas dans
notre pays vous reste à voir quand est
ce qu'on va avoir de nouveau de la
moutarde
monsieur alexandre les filles
istres dans vos explications il ya des
absents tu sais les collectivités
certaines collectivités ont une
augmentation due au coût de
l'électricité de
275% certaines collectivités monte avoir
de grandes difficultés pour payer leurs
factures et vous entendre dire que vous
reprochez à certaines collectivités
d'avoir embauché que maintenant elles
sont en difficulté pour payer leur
facture n'est ni entendable ni recevable
vont-elles devoir augmenter grandement
leurs impôts vont-elles devoir choisir
entre chauffer une école un ehpad un
bâtiment administratif etc monsieur le
ministre
quelles dispositions pensez vous prendre
pour les collectivités quel est le
calendrier de ces mesures et surtout
quelle mesure en fonction de la grandeur
de la collectivité merci merci beaucoup
monsieur lamiraux horizons monsieur le
ministre voudrait parler des des
commerçants de centre-ville
nous avons fait beaucoup d'efforts et un
programme pour aider les petites villes
de demain a été mis en place mais vous
savez ce commerçant ont des loyers qui
sont indexées sur
sur l' indice des loyers commerciaux et
qui malheureusement augmente au niveau
national et malheureusement leur chiffre
d'affaires n'augmente pas aussi fort et
aussi vite que dans d'autres
dans d'autres communes donc elle serait
il pas possible de harmoniser au moins
de régionaliser cet indice de manière à
prendre ça en considération
je vous remercie merci madame shigeru
elle fit
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai une question relative aux
assurances et mutuelles en juillet jeux
de proposer un amendement pour bloquer
le prix des primes d'assurance notamment
pour l'assurance habitation avec les
risques climatiques et j'ai la
confirmation que le secteur de
l'assurance que vous chérissez pour
reprendre un terme de ma collègue et des
mutuelles ont bien prévu d'augmenter les
cotisations et les primes d'assurance
que ce soit pour l'habitation la santé
et les autos donc je vous pose la
question est-ce que vous d'abord vous le
savez très bien puisque je vous ai bien
entendu au mois d'août leur demandait de
limiter ces augmentations
est ce que vous allez prendre des
mesures de boucliers pour limiter en
effet ces augmentations et à combien
dans ce cas là et deuxième question qui
découle c'est que nous allons avoir
plusieurs
mais l'âge des foyers qui ne vont pas
pouvoir faire face à l'augmentation de
ses prix mais ne vont pas pouvoir payer
la prime d'assurance auto ou habitation
qui sont des primes des assurances
obligatoires qu'est ce que l'état va
faire pour ces gens là pour leur
permettre d'être couverts et de voir
leurs risques couverts avec les rires
selim atiku couru merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur gérardin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre une fois de plus l'ensemble des
mesures dont vous venez de nous faire
l'annoncerons aider à préserver notre
modèle économique et protéger les
personnes
à ce jour les aides accompagnant
l'isolation extérieure des bâtiments
sont plutôt faibles au regard du coût de
réalisation de ces travaux pourtant
cette isolation permet des économies
d'énergie de l'ordre de 40 à 50 % une
fois opérationnelles dans ce contexte et
face au mur énergétique est devant nous
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le ministre
qu'il faille aller beaucoup plus loin
dans l'aide à la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments considérant que la
meilleure façon de réduire la facture
énergétique c'est de tout faire pour en
consommer moins je vous remercie merci
madame simone et elle est fille
oui alors tout d'abord monsieur le
président nous parlons fort parce que
nous sommes en colère et j'aime autant
vous dire que c'est insupportable en
fait d'entendre vos remarques seulement
quand il s'agit de femmes qui prennent
la parole donc j'aimerais vraiment que
ça cesse eh bien écoutez excusez moi
mais je le constate donc maintenant ça
suffit alors on parle fort parce que
nous sommes en colère parce que nous
sommes en cas d'heures d'avoir découvert
ces annonces de madame la première
ministre et sans qu'il n'y ait eu aucun
débat démocratique
et finalement c'est toujours une fois de
plus la démocratie parlementaire est
totalement piétiné par un conseil de
défense où les décisions sont prises à
huis clos en colère parce que quand on
apprend que les citoyens citoyennes vont
payer plus de 15% d'augmentation de les
prix de l'électricité du gaz et bien oui
nous sommes en colère nous sommes en
colère parce que le coût de ces de votre
bouclier tarifaire est finalement une
subvention pour ceux justement qui
accumule des super profits est très en
colère quand vous prétendez en plus que
nous mentons et j'en arrive à ma
question merci beaucoup mais ménages qui
repasse par les fournisseurs alternatifs
seront tues la même si je vais donc
profiter on était à une minute je fais
donc profitez-en pour vous répondre
puisque vous m'avez directement
interpellé vous avez tout à fait le
droit d'être en colère j'indique
simplement que d'un point de vue
technique il n'est pas besoin d'exprimer
cette colère de façon trop rapprochée du
micro puisque le micro permet d'être
entendu même quand on parle même quand
on parle loin
deuxième sujet sur la question de faire
la remarque je la fais indistinctement
de tous les groupes politiques et je
préciser madame taurine était présente
lors de la précédente mandature que ses
remarques étaient par exemple fait à
monsieur rufin qui est un homme quand
ils venaient parfois a parlé trop près
du micro ou trop fort donc je fais cette
remarque de façon indistincte que je
m'adresse à une femme ou un homme et je
fais une précision simplement technique
ce qui est que vous pouvez exprimer une
colère sans pour autant vous rapprocher
trop près du micro parce qu'après leçon
stature et nous n'arrivons plus à
entendre nous entendons avec un volume
qui est extrêmement élevé vous faites ce
que vous voulez de la remarque si vous
voulez continuer à parler très près du
micro vous le faites si vous le voulez
je dis juste que j'exprime un sentiment
qui partageait d'ailleurs par beaucoup
de collègues qui est que le micro
fonctionne très bien et qui n'est pas
besoin d'exprimer une colère en étant
trop du micro à prendre ou à laisser
comme vous le souhaitez mais je tiens à
le dire je fait cette remarque à
quiconque quelques soient gros politique
et je fais cette remarque aux femmes et
aux hommes quelle que soit la situation
je la fais en fonction d'un problème
technique je le dis je l'affirmé je
n'accepterai pas d'être attaquée sur cet
angle là je le dis très fermement nous
continuons notre liste monsieur rodwell
pour le groupe renaissance merci
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
merci d'être avec nous cet après midi
tout d'abord certains expliquent que
l'état n'accompagne pas les
collectivités en évoquant par exemple
tout à l'heure le sujet des piscines
municipales
je suis bien placé pour le savoir avec
ma circonscription le ministre et ses
services sont pleinement mobilisés aux
côtés des maires et les piscines
municipales y compris chez moi ré ouvre
ensuite ma question porte sur notre
politique industrielle de l'énergie qui
constitue plus que jamais un enjeu
majeur en la matière le premier
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron a été un
tournant lancement de notre filière
hydrogène relance de notre filière
nucléaire ou encore le rapatriement de
notre production de batteries et de semi
conducteurs ce second quinquennat
démarre et ma question est donc la
suivante quels sont les piliers de votre
politique industrielle de l'énergie pour
ce quinquennat et comment peut-elle
contribuer au rétablissement de notre
balance commerciale
je vous remercie merci donc pour être
parfaitement équitable je vous fais
également la remarque monsieur rodwell
vous pouvez vous pouvez tout à fait vous
exprimer de façon un peu plus joyeuse
lorsqu'il ne sature pas et donc ce n'est
que justice monsieur rodwell messieurs
martin et du groupe elle fit encore
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez
tout à leur proposer aux députés qui
sont en désaccord avec votre politique
énergétique de voyager au royaume uni
pour constater le haut niveau des prix
de l'électricité je vous fait une
contre-proposition un voyage un peu plus
rapproché dans les hlm de ma
circonscription et là vous constaterez
que votre bouclier tarifaire pour ce qui
est du logement collectif ne fonctionne
pas je vais très précis logements
collectifs on parle de copropriétés et
de hlm il n'existe pas de bouclier
tarifaire sur l'électricité dans le
logement collectif et pour ce qui est du
gaz je veux le dire rapidement c'est un
bouclier tarifaire qui fonctionne moins
bien résultat de tout ça là j'ai dans
mon sac les courriers des bailleurs
sociaux envoyé aux locataires expliquant
qu'il y à des augmentations de charles
parfois jusqu'à foix iii jusqu'à 200
euros vous imaginez ce que ça représente
pour un locataires hlm donc ma question
qui est très précise dans ce nouveau
bouclier tarifaire qui vient d'être
annoncé est ce que enfin la question du
logement collectif et donc les
locataires hlm sera pris en compte merci
beaucoup monsieur lopez ligori du
compression nationale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ce lundi vous avez inauguré le
nouveau datacenter dové h et à cette
occasion vous avez annoncé votre volonté
de créer un club s'ouvrait permettez moi
de douter de la crédibilité de vos
annonces vous avez accepté le f table de
microsoft azur vous avez accompagné
l'infiltration microsoft dans le cloud
européen gala x vous avez promu l'accord
thales google deux clubs de confiance en
qui personne n'a confiance vous savez
pourtant que grâce au cloud date le
gouvernement américain un accès total
aux données de leur entreprise je
m'interroge donc sur votre définition de
la souveraineté et du cloud s'ouvrait
vous avez également annoncé la création
d'un label attestant de la sécurité des
services de cloud le sec name cloud ce
label pourrait permettre des services de
cloud l'ayant obtenu d'être utilisées
par certains services de l'état
ma question est donc simple des
entreprises étrangères américaines ou
chinoises comme microsoft google ou
hawaï pourront-elles être certifié merci
merci beaucoup et ce que tout le monde a
pu poser sa question
alors j'ai madame battistel et ce qui
est notre demande de prise de parole
nous pour une dernière question madame
battistel elle hésite oui très
rapidement monsieur le président pour
revenir sur les questions de marché de
l'électricité qui n'a pas fait ses
preuves évidemment chacun le sait et qui
a plutôt fait beaucoup de dégâts donc la
question se pose aujourd'hui sortir du
marché ou réforme est une réforme de
grande ampleur donc monsieur le ministre
voulait simplement avoir votre avis est
ce que vous vous confirmer ce que de vos
collègues disait que la sortie du marché
européen reviendrait se passer de la
solidarité européenne c'est à dire des
importations alors même que chacun le
sait ici ces échanges transfrontaliers
sont bien antérieurs à la mise en place
du marché européen de l'électricité
est ma deuxième question ça concernait
la baisse des impôts de production vous
avez répété que vous y étiez extrêmement
favorable on à la suppression de la cvae
est ce que en parallèle vous
réfléchissez également à une baisse ou à
une suppression de l'ifer mobile ou
l'ifer radio merci bien merci chers
collègues il et 18h13 monsieur le
ministre je crois que vous avez une
contrainte est 18h30 cela vous laisse
donc un peu plus d'une quinzaine de
minutes pour pouvoir répondre à toutes
ces questions merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le président je sais pas
trop me rapprocher du micro
damien dans pour être éligible dans les
déciles 1 et 2 le rfr de 11000 euros ne
vont étendue dont haut des cils 3 et 4
monsieur tivoli vous parlez de l'odieuse
proposition consistant aider l'allemagne
sur le plan énergétique ça nous
permettait aujourd'hui c'est l'allemagne
qui est de la france
puisque nous importons l'électricité en
provenance d'allemagne donc je pense que
davantage les jeter la pierre chez nos
voisins ce qui ne paraît pas très malin
du point de vue européen va mieux se
renseigner sur d'où vient aujourd'hui
l'énergie qui est consommé par les
français nous avons besoin de la
solidarité européenne en matière
énergétique
ça vaut pour l'électricité ça peut
valoir pour d'autres énergies et ça peut
aussi valoir pour les grands projets
d'hydrogène que nous portons
monsieur léné sur edf moi je pense que
plus que la nature d'edf c'est un epic
est-ce que ça va être un établissement
totalement
nationalisée en l'espèce ce sera le cas
ce qui compte c'est surtout de savoir ce
que doit faire odf dans les mois et les
années qui viennent est ce que nous
attendons de df en priorité absolue
c'est la remise en route des réacteurs
qui aujourd'hui sont l'objet de
corrosion sous contrainte 12 réacteurs
c'est de cette capacité d'edf à remettre
en route ses réacteurs que va dépendre
notre capacité à passer un hiver sera
donc c'est la priorité absolue la
deuxième c'est de réaliser le plan sur
les six nouveaux apn qui ont été
demandés par le président de la
république ce qui va supposer en terme
de main d'oeuvre de formation des
investissements considérables et le
troisième c'est de continuer à se
déployer sur les énergies renouvelables
comme edf a commencé à le faire
monsieur marchi choisi initiatives
européennes je vous confirme que nous
nous souhaitons une réforme en
profondeur du marché européen de
l'énergie que nous ne contenteront pas
de simples indications ou de mesures
temporaires
monsieur gaillard / cma-cgm je rappelle
que nous avons demandé s est massée gm
de faire un effort de 500 euros par
container qui l'ont porté à 750 euros
nous avons toujours dit que nous ferions
les comptes pour nous assurer que
effectivement cela bénéfice est bien aux
pme et en l'espèce aux territoires
d'outre-mer qui sont les plus concernés
par le fret maritime donc nous
assurerons que cma-cgm apporte bien sa
contribution au soutien aux ménages et
aux territoires face à l'inflation
brégeon sa production nucléaire oui
c'est une priorité et je pense qu'il
faut bien mesurer à quel point
la question est d'abord une question de
formation de qualification plus que
d'investissement nous avons perdu des
compétences au cours des années passées
il faut les reprendre c'est touchant ce
de l'université des métiers nucléaire
que nous avons mises en place il faut
des soudeurs il faut des chaudronniers
il faut des ingénieurs tout ça va
prendre du temps mais dès lors qu'il ya
un plan de charge devant nous avec six
réacteurs nouveaux qui sont commandés et
8 qui sont à l'étude je pense que ça
doit nous permettre de remettre sur pied
cette
filière qui a souffert des incertitudes
dans le passer
d'un bateau j'ai posé deux questions qui
sont deux questions majeures d'abord sur
le tarif régulier du gaz il faut
effectivement qui les tarifs de
référence qui se substitue à partir du
printemps prochain à ses tarifs régulés
les c'est absolument essentiel parce que
sinon c'est tout le bouclier tarifaire
lui-même qui pourrait être fragilisé ces
lacs requêtes en train de négocier ses
tarifs de référence mais vous avez
raison une indispensable que ces tarifs
de référence soit mise en place
s'agissant des offres pour les
entreprises ou pour les collectivités
locales il est essentiel qu'il y ait des
discussions avec les fournisseurs
d'énergie que le montant des garanties
soit moins élevé qu'il ne l'est
actuellement et que le médiateur de
l'énergie interviennent lorsque
effectivement les discussions ne peuvent
pas aboutir et le sujet que vous
soulevez est un sujet de préoccupation
majeur sur lequel nous demandons
fournisseurs d'énergie de faire preuve
de modération dans les tarifs sous le
contrôle une fois encore de l'état et en
demandant notamment de réduire le
montant des garanties qui fait exploser
sinon la facture aussi bien pour les
entreprises que pour les collectivités
locales
monsieur bothorel sur les dark store
vous savez que nous avons requalifier en
entrepôt ce qui donne la possibilité aux
collectivités locales de régler comme
elle le souhaite et de manière très
autonome le fonctionnement de ces
entrepôts de ses activités économiques
s'agissant de la moutarde nous avons
recoupé importé du canada ce qui me
paraît pas souhaitable
la bourgogne a annoncé qu'elle allait
augmenter sa production ce nul paraît
infiniment plus souhaitable
monsieur alexandre sur les collectivités
moi je veux juste me faire comprendre
nous soutiendrons les collectivités qui
ont le plus besoin mais il me paraît de
bonne politique de regarder celles qui
sont bien gérées et celles qui sont mal
géré il faut pas traiter tout le monde
de la même manière donc il y à des
collectivités qui peuvent avoir engagé
des dépenses de fonctionnement très
lourde
l'argent que nous apportons c'est
l'argent de contribuables à chaque fois
c'est pas comme s'il y avait une caisse
publique avec de l'argent qui vient de
nulle part et bien la poche du
contribuable
donc il me paraît légitime de faire une
distinction entre les collectivités qui
ont bien géré au cours des années
passées et celles qui ont moins bien
gérés cela étant dit une fois encore
nous sommes disposés et très
volontariste pour soutenir des
collectivités locales qui en ont besoin
il ya beaucoup de collectivités qui sont
en grande difficulté alors même qu'elles
sont bien gérées il faut leur apporter
de l'aide
monsieur lamiraux je crois que j'ai
répondu sur l'aspect européen sa
régionalisation de l' indice quand je
suis prêt à regarder ce point là de
manière ouverte
madame chic airways dit tout de suite
que je ne chérit pas particulièrement le
monde de l'assurance la remarque est un
peu gratuites si je peux me permettre
je dis simplement que nous allons
demander aux assureurs exactement ce que
nous avons négocié avec les banques dans
plusieurs semaines négociations qui
étaient franches et parfois difficile
mais qui a abouti avec un plafonnement
du prix des frais bancaires à 2% maximum
en 2023 et pour certaines gel des tarifs
bancaires donc en gros c'est un couloir
de prix qui étaient mis en place entre
le gel et les 2 % d'augmentation
ce qui est une vraie sécurité pour nos
compatriotes moi je le pense que nos
compatriotes ils se disent tous ça c'est
sans fin tout va toujours augmenter plus
ça va être la baguette savez le litre
d'essence à être paquets de pâtes cette
alimentation pour mes enfants ça a été
fourni de l'eau scolaire ensuite ça va
être le tarif de l'assurance habitation
les tarifs de l'assurance auto mes frais
bancaires et c'est ça qui crée l
angoisse et ce qui rassure c'est quand
on sait qu'il y a un bouclier que ça
n'ira pas au delà d'une certaine limite
c'est ça qui permet de faire ses comptes
et de tenir son budget donc moi c'est la
méthode que j'applique à chaque fois
créé sur le gaz ont fait sur
l'électricité on le fait sur les tarifs
bancaires 2% maximum tous les fronts
sans la garantie que quand ils vont
recevoir les frais pour leur carte
bancaire par exemple ce sera pas plus de
2% il faut qu'il y avait une chose pour
les assureurs j'assurerai on m'explique
que l'année 2022 est extraordinairement
difficile mais il était difficile pour
vous le monde n'y a pas de raison que
les assureurs ne contribue pas à eux
aussi à l'effort collectif et je rappel
sur les banques devront aussi obtenu
quelque chose à quoi je suis très
attaché ce public qui sont vraiment en
difficulté ils sont environ 700000 un
peu plus maintenant vous avez des offres
spécifiques pas plus de 1 euro de frais
bancaires par mois maximum alors
qu'avant c'était 3 euros c'est toujours
deux euros d'économisés là aussi je
pense que c'est important de le
souligner
monsieur girardin sur l'aide à la
rénovation énergétique pour le coup moi
je suis tout à fait prêt j'ai déjà dit
je crois que la ministre concerné l'a
dit également avoir un débat approfondi
là dessus je sais que le groupe
écologiste il est très attaché
la rénovation énergétique efficace et
rénovation énergétique globale sinon on
a des ponts thermiques et tout ce que
vous faites comme geste individuel qui
coûte très cher et perdu dans les ponts
thermiques donc je crois que
ouvrir une réflexion sur la manière dont
ma prime rénove dispositif qui
fonctionne remarquablement bien
peut-être transformer un dispositif de
rénovation énergétique globale avec une
efficacité énergétique décuplée je pense
que c'est une très bonne réflexion et
j'y suis favorable
quand on engage d'argent public aussi je
vous assure que c'est efficace en termes
de réduction des émissions de co2 et de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
je pense qu'on peut faire mieux en
matière de rénovation énergétique madame
simonet j'ai entendu votre colère mais
je dépends tendue du coup votre question
donc si vous voulez me la poser à la fin
de
ils seront ils seront à 15% le redit que
le bouclier énergétique concerne tous
les consommateurs d'énergie ils seront
bien 15% et pas à 120% personne ne sera
à 120 % pas question d'avoir des gens
qui vont payer une facture d'électricité
ou de gaz qui explose
je vais préciser ça je finis la 10e des
questions monsieur rodwell sur la
politique industrielle donc j'en donne
juste les trois grands piliers la
formation c'est la clé absolue il faut
rétablir une culture industrielle en
france et que l'industrie redevienne
attractive pour les jeunes qui
choisissent une qualification une
formation on en est loin encore
aujourd'hui et tous les sondages que
nous avons fait de trésor montrent que
l'industrie reste trop rébarbatif pour
les jeunes alors même qu'elle a
radicalement changé
c'est le premier défi le deuxième c'est
l'innovation continuer à financer
l'innovation pour prôner l'industrie qui
reste à la pointe des technologies les
plus avancées l'exemple que vous avez
donnée de globalfoundries et de son
investissement ce semi conducteurs à
crolles est un exemple excellent exemple
trois ans de négociations trois ans de
discussions au bout du compte global
food risque qui s'installe à crolles
geste et micro et la france qui reste
donc dans les cinq ou six états qui
maîtriseront la fonderie de semi
conducteurs jusqu'à 3 nanomètres je
pense que c'est un résultat absolument
stratégique pour notre pays mais ça
passe par de l'innovation et de
l'investissement enfin troisième et
dément il faut rester attractif en terme
fiscal c'est bien pour cela que nous
poursuivons la baisse des impôts de
production monsieur
martin est le bouclier tarifaire pour le
logement collectif alors vous avez tout
à fait raison
nous avions des difficultés avec les hlm
nous avons été saisis je crois que
c'était cet été tous les particuliers
doivent bénéficier du bouclier y compris
ceux qui résident dans des hlm donc s'il
y a encore des difficultés et qu'il y à
des hausses qui passe c'est peut-être
possible je sais très bien contre ce que
nous disons et l'exécution sur le
terrain j'ai même été élu de quartier
difficile à evreux pendant 15 ans donc
je sais à quel point entre ce que nous
disons et ce qui se passe ensuite dans
le quartier de la madeleine à evreux il
peut y avoir un écart tout à fait
important nous sommes prêts à regarder
chacun des cas particuliers pour
apporter des solutions il n'est pas
question d'avoir des hlm qui se
retrouvent les locataires de hlm qui se
retrouvent dans des situations
intenables
du point de vue financier
sur le cloud souverain question qui m'a
été posée par le rassemblement national
moi je vous redis mon hostilité totale à
la législation extraterritoriale
américaine et l'objectif la
certification ccna claude c'est
justement d'avoir une identification des
données sensibles privés ou
professionnels de les sécuriser et
d'interdire toute transmission à la
législation américaine ça sera efficace
aussi si ça se développe au niveau
européen je reconnais pour le coup bien
volontiers qu'il ya encore un débat avec
nos partenaires européens dont certains
estiment que la législation
extraterritoriale américaine ne leur
pose pas de problème moi ça me pose un
sérieux problème car je considère qu'il
n'y a pas de souveraineté ni nationale
ni européenne si une loi d'un autre état
hors de france ou hors de l'europe
s'applique au territoire national au
territoire français ou au territoire
européen donc je le redis mon hostilité
à toute forme de législation
extraterritoriale et légumes claude
protège contre la législation
extraterritoriale américaine en gros le
juge américain ne peut pas venir
récupérer les données qui sont sous ses
tenues mme cloud c'est tout l'objectif
de ce dispositif
sur
le marché européen de la question
faut-il en sortir je crois qu'on a tout
intérêt au contraire à renforcer la
solidarité européenne je prends note
aussi de votre question sur l'ifer
mobile pour l'instant nous contentons ce
qui est déjà beaucoup de supprimer pour
huit milliards d'euros la cvm s'agissant
du bouclier tarifaire je confirme que
tous les français peuvent aller sur
tarifs réglementés de vente tous ils ont
tous la possibilité d'être protégés par
le bouclier tarifaires et tous les
fournisseurs d'électricité qui est soit
alternatifs ou non peuvent proposer les
contrats indexés sur les terres v qui
sont couverts par le bouclier tarifaire
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
pour eux toutes ces réponses merci chers
collègues pour votre participation nous
avons tenu parfaitement le timing je
vous indique simplement que nous notre
prochaine réunion se tiendra mardi 20
septembre nous aurons nous recevrons
monsieur roland lescure manis de
l'industrie à 15h dans le plaisir de le
recevoir 17 heures olivier grégoire
ministre des pme du tourisme de
l'artisanat je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée merci encore monsieur
ministre merci chers collègues